why would you override those guidelines
let's just uh roll back in time for just
a bit and show you a little bit of this
type of woke nonsense that he has pushed
on America over the years uh here he is
on this problem show going after the
Arkansas attorney general Leslie rutage
over child genital mutilation why would
the state of Arkansas step in to
override parents Physicians psychiatrist
endocrinologists who have developed
guidelines why would you override those
guidelines well I think it's important
that all of those Physicians all of
those experts for every single one of
them there's an expert that says we
don't need to allow children to be able
to take those medications that there are
many instances where but you know that's
not true you know it's not for everyone
there's one there's these are the
established well I don't know that
that's not true I don't know that then
why would you why would you pass a law
then if you don't if you don't know that
that's true wouldn't you well I know
that there are doctors and that we had
plenty of people come and testify before
our legislature who said that uh you
know we have 98% of the young people who
have gender dysphoria right are that
they are able to move past that and once
they have the the help that they need no
longer suffer from gender dysphoria 98%
without that medical treatment that's an
incredibly madeup figure that's that
doesn't comport with any of the studies
or documentation that exists from these
medical organizations what what Medical
Association are you talking about of
these doctors well we have all of that
in our uh legislative history and we'll
be glad to provide that to you I don't
have the name of that off the top of my
head I know it's something that you
don't have the name of the
organization that that you're get top my
head oh okay but yes we have all of that
sided in all of our briefs you're
suggesting that protecting children
means overriding the recommendations of
the American Medical Association the
American Association of Pediatrics the
endocrine Society we don't have enough
data we don't have enough to show that
these drugs are effective and that these
children are better off I mean it goes
on and on what an absolutely smug
unlikable person he became for the cool
1 million ion plus per episode he was
making on that now defunct show so then
the machine brings him back owned by
Viacom um you might want to read uh
maybe John Stewart if you're watching
this you might want to read irreversible
damage uh by Abigail shrier thank you uh
who wrote an incredible book about how
so much of what's happening to our
children is a social contagion
particularly when it comes to young
girls thinking they can transition and
become young boys now this that clip was
from a couple years ago but we know how
much of this has ruined young people's
lives like why is John Stewart so smug
about chemically castrating children
that the state would be a little
concerned about that about drugging
children so that they can't go through
puberty and everything else but this is
what the left has pushed on us and John
Stewart was sort of put out there as the
respectable face of all of this and then
of course what happens is you get all of
these bad policies you literally are
going after children that woman you
think she's a bad woman the Attorney
General
there you think she's a bad woman or
she's just trying to protect children
because no you cannot take a boy and
actually make them a girl that's just
not
reality